planches de bois fixée devant les
vitrines les commerçants comme les
autorités locales craignent des
débordements les magasins de washington
se prépare à l'arrivée de milliers de
supporters pro trump 340 membres de la
garde nationale sont déployés dans la
capitale fédérale le port d'armes à feu
ne sera pas tolérée les plus fervents
partisans de donald trump rejette comme
lui la victoire de joe biden et accuse
le camp démocrate de fraude
donald trump a gagné le soir de
l'élection
ce à quoi nous assistons est une
révélation complète de la corruption du
système
la façon dont il a été corrompu et nous
en tant qu'américains nous reprenons
notre système il amérique devrait
interdire les démocrates menteurs et
tricheurs qui veulent prendre l'amérique
pour le socialisme et non pour les
américains ils ne sont pas là pour nous
ils sont là pour eux mêmes ils
remplissent leurs poches avec notre
argent ils n'essaient pas de s'occuper
des américain donald trump n'a pas
appelé ses partisans à le soutenir à
washington par hasard c'est ce mercredi
qu'a lieu la réunion du congrès qui doit
officialiser la victoire du président
élu joe biden
comme à son habitude c'est sur twitter
qu'il motive ses troupes
washington est en train d'être inondés
de gens qui ne veulent pas voir une
victoire électorale volés par les
radicaux de gauche démocrates notre pays
en a eu assez ils ne l'accepteront plus
on vous entend et on vous aime depuis le
bureau ovale make america great games
donald trump continue d'accuser les
démocrates de fraude mais depuis le 4
novembre aucun des recours en justice
des républicains n'a abouti jusqu'à
présent silencieux le président sortant
doit donner un discours très attendu cet
après midi face à ses supporters depuis
la maison blanche